we are now in the home of a Naheed
lecturer on Armenian studies and I need
to learn the Armenian language and I
realize it's a difficult language we
just visited sona's home and her entire
family in the living room started
speaking to one another in Armenian and
it sounded like a bunch of Dracula's an
auctioneer sometimes I pretend to speak
a language but I don't is that
considered offensive if I spoke fake
Armenian crabby ho their offensive very
the class is going to start with with a
greeting right agree we say hello ok but
if but if perfect but n o addresses what
was that what you say how are you it's
precious another thing you might
encounter mr. O'Brien please call me dr.
O'Brien just great armenian phrases for
me to know so tell them a few nice words
that they feel happy
tell them g-get g-get g-get g-get yes
perfect me liver I eat your liver yeah
[Music]
that's a serial killer your liver learn
but but say to people who you feel close
with what is the freight what's the
translation in English of this race I
die on your body I die in your body
what's wrong with you people
I want to eat your liver I want to die
on your body language armed with four of
the creepiest phrases ever I booked a
flight to take us to Armenia
[Music]
[Applause]
you